but a lot of time like it like
especially with NFL guys who played for
like 10 12 years and then 10 years go by
and they want to sue the NFL to them
right yeah yeah yeah or the UFC fighter
who want who's gets on Twitter and
starts shouting at Dana White's like
homeboy
you knew it Jane yeah what'd you think
was gonna happen
what do you were they supposed to take
care of everybody when you're done but
also like loss um well most boxers were
approached don't make money right would
you say most boxers who are pros don't
make money right most boxers like the
guys in the undercard the but no you
know I'm saying the game did that but
they know this but do any of these to
get to Floyd Mayweather but that's what
they signed up for what percentage of
those people who are professional say
UFC what percentage of people who are
considered professional fighters would
you say make a good level 5% that's it
that's and to the other 95 acting was
acting any different I mean will stand
up any splits Taylor's the same thing
but less than 1% we have and we have no
we have no net we don't have like
unemployment or benefits we don't have
unions nothing like that anything else
but now they do the UFC guys two out of
that five percent do a do chunk of them
make money do line make money though
yeah I guess that depends on like
earning like I would say majority of
them are there they're fighting for a
living like I know a check to pay check
yo yeah with roommates guys you'd know
so I know by the way that's what I did a
deep dive a wife in chapatti building no
I mean it's not it's you know it's like
that's that's like a job like if yeah if
your job if you work for ups and your
job back in cowboy like I talked to him
candidly before all before he became
like even like three years ago he wasn't
making much money you know you had to
find make much money 80 80 or whatever
six you've got a fight explain five
times a year and then yes monsters
Cowboys making money yeah how does
making my how much if you make a hundred
sixty-four fight how much of that goes
out to your people your can 10% goes
your management so you know and you're
paying for the camp though right okay
for the kid what about what would you
can't cost you I don't know 30 grand no
not that much 15 how long's camp most
guys do 6 to 8 weeks and your manager
gets what 10% 10% and how many people in
the car
like summer I told you Jeffrey do you
mean yeah okay no no you got a pic well
that's that's camp cost okay
your manager would be like Lex would get
10% my fight stuff because he negotiated
the contract they really don't need them
these days all managers Fork is the FCC
they don't really play the clock so now
it's like you just need a manager or an
agent to get you sponsor you you'll do
what they tell you you'll take the fight
they tell you to take right correct yes
what percentage of those guys like what
percentage of their money comes from
sponsorships or outside now not many
dude when when Nate was at my house Nate
who Marquart and this is Lenny yeah he
he got a call from me from little Joe
Silva and Joe self said you're fighting
and they said I can't make that weight
right now and he goes well cut you and
he was like what thing is your fight he
goes and he had it was like a crisis and
I was like I'll just cut you you're one
of the best what the [ __ ] are they
talking his fight business dude that's
not right imagine think it is right
don't me again good but this like game
you signed up for I don't like when
people cry about that's the game you
sign up well it's like you for
quarterbacks I can't do any get you in
and you're searching like dude I
wouldn't [ __ ] it I'm not peeking
I was planning on going out longer if
you just create we what we're gonna move
on we can't use you
yeah that's the game yeah you imagine I
mean if they yeah some of those rules
were me hardiest about it I was never
because I was pissed about Reebok cos2x
money absent I was never pissed about
match it like I knew the game and you
just accepted what are you gonna do
those fighters don't care I mean they're
fighters man if they had those kind of
rules in comedy well there are there are
those rules and nobody gives a [ __ ]
about you in comedy not and you make
people laugh yeah and and it's up to you
to get people that will do and go to
pray up bomb every night and see if they
have you back yeah or did that happen to
somebody in this room know if you don't
do well oh yeah I don't perform yeah
well if you don't know it I'll take it
to you you can also do well but if you
don't sell take it yes that's it yeah
it doesn't matter sell tickets that's it
because
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue okay what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do
use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]